And 2001 was important film for me because I didn't understand it when I saw it
Our dad had taken me and I was so frustrated by the movie
and kind of hated the movie
when I first saw it I was like
*grrrrr*
What is that stupid black thing?
*laughing*
*mumbling*
... Stupid...
*laughing*
And I was like "I didn't get what was the black thing" and he said that's a symbol and I kind of like knew what the word was
But then suddenly I had a visual understanding of what the word was
I was like "A symbol of what?"  and he said "Uh it's kind of like a symbol for the
Consciousness of God", I didn't even understand what that meant
But it sounded amazing and so then I asked him to take me back to see it again
and I saw it again and then whenever I saw the symbol I thought of like "God" and
it made more sense to me suddenly and this was like a strange phenomenon that you could suddenly
Look at something and then have different eyes and see it again and understand it in a completely different way
"The answer is out there Neo
It's looking for you"
"Let me tell you why you're here
You're here because you know something. What you know, you can't explain but you feel it
You felt it your entire life. You don't know what it is, but it's there. It is this feeling that has brought you to me
Do you know what I'm talking about?"
Filmmaker Lily Wachowski formerly known as Andy came out publicly as transgender on Tuesday
Something her sister and creative partner Lana did years before
There's a critical eye being cast back on Lana's and my work through the lens of our transness
"It seems that you've been living... two lives"
I finally came out to my family
When I told my mom what was going on she jumped on a plane immediately
There was this big tear-soaked baptism
And she confessed that she'd been afraid to come here. To arrive and grieve the loss of her son
"Am I dead?"
"Far from it"
But when she arrived she found it wasn't so much as a death as it was a discovery.
"I just thought um...
You were a guy..."
"Most guys do"
That there was this other part of me. An unseen part.
She felt it was like a gift because now she could get to know that part of me
"One of this lives... Has a future. And one of them does not."
I stare into a mirror. Boy, mirrors can be tough for all of us, but trans people... That can be brutal.
"Like everyone else you were born into bondage. Born into a prison that you cannot smell or taste or touch.
A prison for your mind."
I kept this strange relentless vigil staring in the mirror for hours afraid of what one day I might see
"You have to see it for yourself"
The enduring power of the Cinderella Myth is this catharsis, this fitting of a slipper
representing this intersection of who we see in the looking-glass with who we want to be
"Your appearance now is what we call Residual Self Image
It is the mental projection of your digital self"
"I'm going to show them a world without you
a world without rules and controls. Without Borders or boundaries
A world where anything is possible"
Here one checked box. One letter. an M
granted me access to legal social financial privilege while another box, another letter, an F, denied them to me
Early on I am told to get in line after a morning bell. Girls in one line, Boys in the other
I walk past the girls feeling this strange powerful gravity of association
As soon as I look towards the other line though, I feel a feeling of differentiation that confuses me
I don't belong there either. I stop in between them
"Where we go from there is a choice I leave to you"
"You hear that Mr. Anderson?
That is the sound of inevitability"
When I see the headlight I take off my backpack and I put it on the bench. And this is the note in front of it
I try not to think of anything but jumping as the train comes
"It is the sound of your death
Goodbye Mr. Anderson"
We went to dinner I dress as feminine as I could wanting to be seen by strangers as Lana
Hoping that waiters would not call me  "Sir", or "He"
"My name...
Is Neo!"
"Hi I'm Lynne, this is my daughter Lana" the waitress smiled and said "wow, she looks just like you"
Of all the things I love about my hair
High on the list is the way children stare at it with fascination and delight
I can sometimes see their imagination bright in their eyes, recalibrating the possible
It is my hope that a symbol like pink dreads might help them understand
"normal" is something that does not have to be defined for you, but rather by you
I am here because when I was young I wanted very badly to be a writer
I wanted to be a filmmaker, but I couldn't find anyone like me in the world and it felt that my dreams were foreclosed
Simply because my gender was less typical than others
It's an excellent reminder that art is never static and while the ideas of identity and transformation are
critical components in our work the bedrock that all ideas rest upon is love
You can't be dead
You can't be
Because I love you
I know I am also here because of the strength and courage and love that I'm blessed to receive from my wife my family and my friends
And in this way, I hope to offer their love in the form of my materiality
So this world that we imagined in this room that might be used to gain access to other rooms to other worlds previously unimaginable
He told me I wasn't really looking for him. I was looking for an answer
It's the question that drives us Neo
It's the question that brought you here. You know the question, just as I did
What is the Matrix?
The Matrix remains relevant today because there are so many different ways to interpret the movie
you could just as easily have made a video about the Matrix through the lens of Philosophy Marxism or even Buddhism
There's no correct way to interpret a movie but certain interpretations can give us powerful insights into the world we live in
Or even an idea of what some people are going through
Part of the power of the Internet is how it gives us access to these unique perspectives
But it can sometimes be tough to separate the good content from the bad
To save time and focus on great content I highly recommend the documentaries on Curiosity Stream
Curiosity Stream is a subscription streaming service with over 2000 documentaries and nonfiction titles from some of the world's best filmmakers
These documentaries can present ideas to you in a completely fresh way
I recommend their video on the birth of the Internet ,
a close look at the political motivations behind one of mankind's most important inventions
Go to curiositystream.com/nowyouseeit for unlimited access to the world's top documentaries
Enter the promo code "nowyouseeit" when prompted during the signup process
and your membership is completely free for the first 30 days
Thanks for watching